hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel
revealed a whole bunch of stuff about
Avengers infinity warp you know purple
floating Chairman so this is going to be
a breakdown so as you can imagine the
official title for Avengers infinity War
part 1 is just Avengers infinity war
they pretty much did the same thing that
Geoff Johns did when Justice League was
starting production people were like
what is the first part of the movie
going to be called what's the second
part going to be called and Geoff Johns
was like just to clear the air there's
no subheading the first Justice League
movie is just called Justice League so
the first Avengers infinity war movie in
that same tone is just going to be
called Avengers infinity war
nice and simple a really catchy title
that immediately tells you exactly what
the action of the movie is going to be
and sets off all these warning alarms in
comic book readers heads like oh my god
then you start thinking about all the
fan oohs Infinity Gauntlet storylines so
the real question is is what they're
going to name the second infinity war
movie
so the Russos are actually directing
both of those and that wasn't clear but
they did say like the reason for
changing the title between the first and
the second movie is just to let you know
that they're going to be very different
movies it's not going to be like one big
movie just chopped in half because we
kind of have gotten to that place like
The Hobbit for instance where they turn
what should be one movie into like three
or even four movies I predict that some
day in the not-too-distant future there
will be a studio that tries to milk a
franchise for all it's worth and will
try to turn the last movie of a trilogy
into four movies just so they can boost
their profits for the next couple of
years but in Marvel's case there are
just so many stories that build into
Thanos assembling the Infinity Gauntlet
in how the Avengers get it off of his
hand how they fix the universe because
even though the Avengers movies are all
very high concept you're dealing with
like really trippy ideas danos in the
Infinity Gauntlet take that to new
levels so that's why they've had to kind
of weave him in very slowly that was one
of Joss Whedon's earliest suggestions to
Marvel when he started working with them
they were making the first Avengers film
and in Thanos was a much bigger part of
it and he's like whoa whoa whoa pump the
brakes on this you have to thread him in
much slower so you have ideas like fan
oohs infinity Crusade infinity quest
Infinity Ward that was actually the name
of one of the stories infinity war but I
think what we're all expecting at least
from this first film is that
a nose will assemble the gauntlet and he
will do something crazy like he'll snap
his fingers like he did in the comics
he'll erase half of life in the universe
and then the story of the next Avengers
film will be the Avengers dealing with
that fixing it
getting the glove off of his hand but in
terms of titles for that fourth Avengers
film like the second part of the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline
I think it'll either be Avengers
infinity dot dot dot something else like
Avengers infinity crusade or some other
derivative of the idea of infinity or
they'll just call it New Avengers which
is actually a separate title in the
comics so don't confuse New Avengers in
the comics with what's going on in the
movies but by the time we get to that
fourth Avengers film there will actually
be a lot of New Avengers Captain Marvel
most notably but let me know in the
comments what do you think the title of
the fourth Avengers film is going to be
do you think it's going to be new
Avengers do you think it's going to be
infinity crusade do you think it's going
to be some other derivative of infinity
it makes sense that it would but I could
understand if they want to choose
something that's completely different
just so that you don't confuse it with
infinity war and just to catch up with
purple floaty chair glove wearing man I
totally love this picture this is
actually taken from the footage that
they showed at thor ragnarok like the
funny documentary that i talked about in
my other video we all know about the
visions that thor had during Avengers
age of Ultron he has a vision of the
glove being assembled and he's just like
oh my god I need to figure out what's
going on so he flies back to Asgard and
that's the last we see of him but from
what we've learned about thor ragnarok
in the behind-the-scenes footage they
showed at comic-con he's actually all
dressed up like Braveheart fighting in
an arena against the Hulk while Loki in
the Grandmaster are cackling twiddling
their thumbs watching them so very
clearly something has gone off the rails
in Asgard so we'll find out about that
in Thor Ragnarok but because this
picture flows from Thor Ragnarok that's
the next movie that's going to touch
base with them James Gunn has already
confirmed that Thanos is nowhere to be
found anywhere in guardians of the
galaxy - we might see the soul gem but
that's the closest it's going to get to
Avengers infinity war storyline kind of
flowing from that idea to Doctor Strange
relatively self-contained movie even if
we see the time gem we probably won't
see daños so let me know what you think
that Thanos is going to be doing in Thor
Ragnarok personally I think the easiest
prediction is that he's going to raid
Odin's
fault he's gonna come calling on Loki
for the things that he helped him with
he like I gave you the scepter with the
mind gem now I'm coming to collect I
want the gems so you can understand how
Loki is hedging his bets aligning
himself with one of the other elders of
the universe the Grand Master very
powerful person probably not quite as
powerful but he's Loki's just trying to
make as many friends as he can in high
places because he still owes him a debt
and Game of Thrones style Lannisters
always pay their debts so it'll be
really fun to see Loki interact with a
nose but giveaway time congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Branden
Crespo you had a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to private message be on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details the Marvel giveaway is
still going on too so all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video there'll be a
couple more Marvel videos this weekend I
know I haven't done a Black Panther
video in a while - they did reveal quite
a bit of stuff about the movie at Comic
Con but they haven't started making it
so there really isn't any footage for it
yet so a whole bunch more comic book
stuff happening this weekend get hype
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my breakdown
to the Thor Ragnarok footage you can
click here for my breakdown of the
guardians of the galaxy to footage thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you